elle nous embarque pour maryse bonsoir
bonsoir
alors je t'avouerai que quand il a été
question de t'inviter dans notre
émission j'étais pas très chaud je
t'avais vu dans une émission sur tf1
carton skate sur l'épée je trouve ça
très vulgaire et j'y suis allé un peu à
reculons
ma femme a pas voulu venir est ce que tu
crois que ton image dans les média te
correspondent
je crois que en spectacle on peut que tu
sais tout ça c'est un peu entouré ça
passe ça passe beaucoup mieux moi je
fous alors j'y suis allé au palais des
glaces et j'ai vu sept cents personnes
tous les soirs clients 2 je t'ai vu sur
scène pendant une heure et demie un peu
de lumière pas beaucoup d'accessoires
pas de décor et tu fais marrer tout le
monde et je voulais le dire et c'est
pour ça que finalement je suis très
heureux de t'avoir invité ce soir je
remercie tirer turbo à quelque chose
c'est mieux que j'arrête
alors c'est très chouette parce que tu
tu prends ton vulgaire au deuxième degré
contenus comment tu fais c'est à dire
que j'ai je préférerais moins
revendiquer la vulgarité c'est que la
réunion des comics jeux l'expliquent
bien j moi on m'a donné jules guerre
j'essaie de le faire le mieux possible
et en plus tu démonte le mécanisme du
spectacle c'est à dire que sans arêtes
explique le cheminement du spectacle
fait des bilans régulièrement et ce qui
est le meilleur moyen c'est de ces deux
de faire rentrer les gens dans les
coulisses du spectacle leur montrer
comment il faut faire pour faire rigoler
les gens et puis d'y arriver quand même
quand il ya chez de lentilles spectacle
faire évidemment les gens sont morts de
rire et sourire tout un joueur 1 c'est
bravo c'est bien on l'applaudît jean
marie bigard
en quantité de l'humanitaire en
utilisant le vulgaire un peu comme
coluche non c'est en mètres coolus
abbaoui j'ai tellement d'admiration pour
pour ce mec ça me colle un peu à la peau
j'espère bien faire du bigard mais c'est
vrai que si je suis d'un sillon je suis
dans le sillon de coluche quoi tu parle
beaucoup dans son spectacle des grands
moments de solitude près les laissés
pour compte des clodos les éjaculateurs
précoces et et les gens sortent de la
vachement mieux que quand ils sont
rentrés et c'est vrai parce qu'il ya
plus un buste et touchaient des points
qui sont souvent un peu intime c'est
vrai que tu quand on se retrouve un jour
dans des chutes de camping le verrou il
ferme pas obligés de tenir la porte
c'est comme ça puis tu te retournes
manifestement il ya déjà quelqu'un qui
est passé avant toi même ils sont mis à
plusieurs pour ça si parce qu'il ya deux
couleurs différentes
tutti à la chasse d'eau il n'y a pas
d'eau qui coule tu tires le papier reste
plus qu'une feuille à ce moment là tu
dis je vais ressortir
et puis là ya un gars qui tape à la
porte pour rentrer alors j'ai dit si je
sors il va croire que c'est à moi le
gros truc tout pile à valga il retape à
la bob alors on est en plein dedans
c'est un grand nom grand tu parle aussi
des handicapés est ce que finalement se
moquer les handicapés c'est pas déjà un
moyen de s'en occuper
ah oui disons qu'on est plus près d'eux
que tu on s'en moque quand on n'en parle
pas